Speaker 1: If you thought Mike Pence's campaign
announcement in Iowa yesterday was bad, just
wait until you get a look at his CNN town
hall, which was hosted by Dana Bash.
You know, one of the things that is very interesting
to see with these modern right wingers is
how quickly their talking points fall apart,
not when presented with opposition per se
from the other side, but simply when there
is any follow up.
And Dana Bash, as you will see during some
of these clips, provides just really simple
questions that Mike Pence at some point doesn't
even know how to respond to now.
To his credit, I will say Pence is starting
to draw some distinction with Donald Trump.
And you've got to do that if you're going
to justify people voting for you instead of
Trump when you served under Trump, why would
they go for the number two if they liked the
number one when number one is running?
Okay, you understand that?
Here is Pence saying Trump thinks Putin's
a genius.
I think Putin is a war criminal.
All right.
At least it's a distinction.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump said in his CNN town
hall he was asked whether he wanted Ukraine
to win the war and he would not say.
What message does that send to Vladimir Putin?
Speaker 3: Well, and frankly, when Vladimir
Putin rolled into Ukraine, the former president
called him a genius.
Oh, I know the difference between a genius
and a war criminal.
Right.
And I know who needs to win in the war in
Ukraine.
And it's the people fighting for their freedom
and fighting to restore their national sovereignty.
And Ukraine and America.
It's not our war.
But freedom is our fight and we need to give
the people of Ukraine the ability to fight.
Speaker 1: And the time for even the applause
is milquetoast.
Like, it's not just the answers.
Nobody seems in any way inspired by this.
But listen to Pence's credit.
There are other people running in this Republican
primary who aren't even willing to say that.
So credit where credit is due.
Even if it's for pathetically small things.
Now, here was a really interesting moment.
Dana Bash seemed to visibly stumped Mike Pence
when she pointed out, you know, deterrence,
claiming that the death penalty for shootings
will be a deterrent doesn't make sense when
many of the mass shooters want to be killed.
And Pence was visibly stumped by this.
A very interesting.
Speaker 2: Moment.
Quickly, go back to something you said about
expediting the processing of people who engage
in mass shootings.
A lot of people who are mass shooters, they
go in with the intention to die.
Right.
So how would the threat of execution be a
deterrent?
Speaker 3: Well.
I follow these stories closely as you do.
And of course, our years in the White House,
we saw one tragedy after another.
And I know we hear that and we we see evidence
oftentimes in the aftermath that they went
in without regard to whether they would survive.
Right.
But I just believe in the deterrent of the
law are and I believe perhaps if if we made
it clear I mean, think about this.
The Parkland shooter is going to spend the
rest of his life in jail.
Drew in Florida.
And that's not justice.
Speaker 1: Okay.
He believes in the deterrent of law.
But that passing stricter gun laws wouldn't
make a difference.
How is that possible?
The death penalty would be a deterrent, even
though, as Dana Bash correctly points out,
many of these shooters plan to die.
They want to die.
Sometimes they take their own lives if they
aren't taken by by first responders.
So that's going to be a deterrent.
But stricter gun laws won't be a deterrent.
That doesn't really make any sense.
It's as incoherent as many of these modern
Republican positions.
Mike Pence talked falsely about how Democrats
want abortion on demand until the moment of
birth, which of course, isn't true.
And Dana Bash points that out.
Speaker 3: At the Democrat Party's position
is abortion on demand with taxpayer dollars
all the way up to the moment of.
Speaker 1: Birth?
Says who?
Speaker 3: And as we talk about the possibility
of a national standard, say, a 15 week standard,
which would put America more in line with
most of the European Union, most of the European
countries have either a 12 to 15 week rule
on abortion.
Our laws today are more in line with China,
Iran and North Korea.
And for my part, if I have the great privilege
to serve as president of the United States,
I'll all support the cause of life at every
level, the state level, the local level with
taxpayer dollars and at the national level.
Speaker 2: And just the person you're running
against or you want to run against if you
get the nomination is President Biden.
He says that codifying Roe versus Wade is
his position.
That means a right to an abortion until the
point of viability, not up until until birth.
Speaker 1: And Mike Pence smirking at being
told the truth about the widespread opposition
from Joe Biden on that issue.
On the question of Trump's crimes, Pence seems
to be going with yes, Trump committed crimes
and attempted to violate the Constitution,
but we kind of should just move on with no
consequences.
Speaker 3: I think now more than ever, we
ought to be finding ways we could actually
come together.
We're going to get this kind of this kind
of action by the Department of Justice, I
think would only fuel further division in
the country.
And let me also say, I think it would also
send a terrible message to the wider world.
I mean, we are the we're the emblem of democracy.
We're the symbol of justice our way.
And the really the serious matter, which has
already happened once in New York.
Of indicting a former president of the United
States sends a terrible message to the world.
I hope the DOJ thinks better of it or resolves
these issues without an indictment.
Speaker 2: I just want to clarify what you're
saying is that if they believe he committed
a crime, they should not go forward with an
indictment.
You just talked before about.
No.
Speaker 1: By the way, anybody else noticing
how Pence does this weird thing where while
Dana Bash is talking to him, he doesn't look
at her.
He just looks out into the middle distance.
It's a very strange thing.
And Pence does this to a lot of people.
Speaker 2: I think, to the rule of law.
Speaker 3: Let me be clear that no one's above
the law.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 3: But with regard to the unique circumstances
here.
Speaker 1: No one's above the law.
But but, but.
Okay, just a couple more of these.
Pence says that he has no interest in pardoning
the individuals convicted for rioting on January
6th.
Speaker 3: The Constitution says.
Speaker 2: Sure on that.
Donald Trump says he is, quote, inclined to
pardon many members of the mob who attacked
the Capitol on January six.
Those people were, of course, part of the
same mob who built gallows and chanted about
wanting to hang you.
Right.
Would you consider parting and pardoning any
of them?
Speaker 3: You know, on the day of January
six, I issued a tweet demanding that people
leave the folks.
Speaker 1: He tweeted.
Speaker 3: And end the violence.
And I said that those that failed to do that
should be prosecuted to the fullest extent
of the law.
Right.
And I continue to believe that today we cannot
ever allow what happened on January six to
happen again in the heart of our democracy.
What about the stand by the decisions and
the due process of court in our laws?
And I have no interest or no intention of
pardoning those that assaulted police officers
or vandalized our Capitol.
Speaker 1: All right.
Now understand that even there he's saying
he has no interest in pardoning those who
assaulted police officers or vandalized the
Capitol.
But if there are people who were charged for
other things, he doesn't seem to be ruling
that out, although with Pence, you never really
know what he means with his slippery language.
And then lastly, Pence refusing to rule out
pardoning Donald Trump if he were to be elected
president.
Sir, if Donald Trump.
Speaker 2: If Donald Trump is convicted of
a crime.
And you're elected president.
Would you pardon him?
Speaker 3: Well, I don't want to speak about
hypotheticals.
Oh.
I'm not sure I'm going to be elected president
of the United States.
Speaker 1: I'm sure that you're not.
But okay, Dana, I'm going to decline to answer
that on the basis that I have absolutely no
path to the nomination whatsoever.
And I don't even know why I'm really here.
So on that basis, I'm going to decline to
answer that question.
Speaker 3: But I believe we have a fighting
chance.
I really believe we do.
Speaker 2: And if you are.
Speaker 3: And I would hope again, Dana, in
your ear, as persistent as ever.
CNN is living up to its reputation.
And look, there are real issues the American
people are facing.
And rather than talking about that, I want
to talk about.
Speaker 1: So he doesn't want to answer that
question.
So a disastrous campaign launch for Mike Pence,
no path to the nomination.
But could he end up helping Trump in Trump's
path to the Republican nomination?
We'll talk about that maybe tomorrow, maybe
on Monday